I don't deny that there are real serious
problems with marriage in our society
the so-called red pill people and others
they raise totally legitimate and
important points on that end we need
drastic reform abolish no fault divorce
the entire family court system has to be
torn down and rebuilt the system is
stacked against men in many ways that
are extremely unfair and have ruined
countless lives so let's fight for those
reforms absolutely but this systemic
problem is not going to be solv today or
tomorrow or next week abolishing no
fault divorce is just the beginning of
reforming the system system lawmakers in
a small number of red states have only
just started to seriously consider that
idea which is merely step one we're a
long way off from fixing the system it
to it took decades to get us here it
will take decades to get us out at best